The final step of this pipeline is to assess
how good our model is through performance
evaluation. Evaluation of predictive models is
one of the most crucial steps in the pipeline.
The basic idea is to develop the
model using some training samples,
but test this train model on some other
unseen samples, ideally from future data.
It is important to note that the training error
is not very useful, because you can very easily
over fit the training data by using complex models
which do not generalize well to future samples.
Testing error is the key metric because
it’s a better approximation of the true
performance of the model on future samples.
The classical approach for evaluation is
through cross-validation process or CV.
The main idea behind cross-validation
is to iteratively split a data set
into training and validation sets. And we
want to view the model on the training set,
and test the model on the validation
step, but do this iteratively, many times.
Finally, the performance matrix are
aggregated across this iterations
often by taking the average. There are
three common methods for cross-validations
namely Leave-1-out cross-validation, k-fold
cross-validation, and randomized cross-validation.
In Leave-1-Out cross validation, we take
one example at a time as our validation set
and use the remaining set as the training set.
Then repeat this process many times,
goes through the entire data set.
The final performance is computed by averaging
the prediction performance across all iterations.
K-Fold’s cross variation is very similar
to leave-1-out validation. But instead of
just using one example of validation set, we
have multiple samples in the validation set.
More specifically, we split the entire data
set into K-Folds. And we iteratively choose
each fold as set, validation set and use
the remaining Folds as a trimming set.
For example, the Fold 1 would be used as the
validation set, and the remaining fold will
be used as a trimming set to view the model.
Then we use a Fold 2 as the validation set,
the remaining fold as the training set to be
build another model. And repeat this process
K times, and the final performance is the
average over this four different models.
Finally, randomized cross validation will randomly
split the data set into training and testing.
For each such split, the model is fit to the
training data set, and the prediction accuracy
is assessed using the validation set. The
result are then averaged over all the splits.
The advantage of this method over the
K-fold cross validation is that the
proportion of the training and validation
set is not depends on the number of fold.
The disadvantage of this method is that
some observation may never be selected
Into the validation set because there’s
randomization process. Whereas, some other
samples may be selected more than ones into
the validation set. validation set may overlap.
To conclude, in this lecture, we introduced
the key steps in building a predictive model.
Which include define what is the prediction
target and construct the right patient cohort,
then construct all the possible relevant features
from data, then find which features are relevant,
and view the predictive model, and
finally, evaluate the model performance.